BUT FIRST, THE RELENTLESS ABUSE
OF POWER, THAT’S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
TODAY’S DOJ ANNOUNCEMENT THAT IT
WAS DROPPING MIKE FLYNN’S
PROSECUTION IS FANTASTIC NEWS
COME A LONG OVERDUE.
WHERE DOES GENERAL FLYNN GO TO
GET THE PAST THREE YEARS BACK OR
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS HE LOST
DEFENDING HIMSELF, OR THE PAIN
AND SUFFERING IT BECAUSE HIM AND
HIS FAMILY?
AS HAPPY AS I AM FOR HIM AND I’M
HAPPY, I’M UTTERLY DISGUSTED
THIS COULD HAVE EVER HAPPENED TO
A DECORATED WAR VET COME AT ANY
AMERICAN WHO JUST WANTED TO
SERVE HIS GOVERNMENT ONE MORE
TIME AS NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
WHAT THEY DID TO FLYNN IS WHAT
YOU GET FOR WORKING FOR A
GOVERNMENT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
DON’T LIKE.
WHAT THEY DID TO FLYNN IS MERELY
A PART OF A FOCAL YEAR CONTINUUM
CONTINUUM, THAT WOULD BENEFIT
ALL OF US BY THE WAY.
THEY SAW HIS VICTORY, IN 2016 AS
A SIN FOR WHICH TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS MUST BE PUNISHED AND
THEIR CREDO IS RULE OR RUIN.
WE WILL EITHER RULE THE COUNTRY
OR WE WILL RUIN IT.
AND THEY HAVE WORKED OVERTIME TO
ACCOMPLISH THE LATTER.
TONIGHT WE ARE NAMING NAMES,
MEMBERS OF AN ABUSE OF POWER
HALL OF SHAME.
THESE STORIES CAN’T BE
UNDERSTOOD IN ISOLATION, THEY
ARE ALL EVIDENCE OF A DEEPLY
UNDEMOCRATIC STRAIN THAT IS
BECOMING A CANCER ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY METASTASIZING
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE BODY
POLITIC.
BEFORE THE FBI’S EFFORT TO
ENTRAP FLYNN, THE OBAMA INTEL
CHIEF AND THE OBAMA DOJ AND FBI
PUT IN MOTION THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION.
THEY ABUSED THEIR POWER AGAINST
LOW-LEVEL AIDES LIKE GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
THEY ABUSE THEIR POWER IN FILING
AT PFIZER APPLICATIONS TO SURVEY
ALL CARTER PAGE.
AND THEY ABUSE THEIR POWER IN
THE LYING ON A RUSSIAN DOSSIER
FUNDED BY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
EVEN WHEN THEY COULD NOT VERIFY
ITS CLAIMS.
FBI DIRECTOR COMEY ABUSED HIS
POWER, AND THE ENTIRE FLYNN SAGA
AS WELL.
SO AN ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
SALLY GATES WHO ALLOWED AN
INTERVIEW WITH THE PRESIDENT’S
NEW NSA CHIEF TO GO FORWARD AND
OF COURSE THERE WAS THE CRICKET
FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK AND HIS
INSURANCE POLICY THAT HE
MENTIONED TO HIS LOVEBIRD
LISA PAGE.
THEY WENT AFTER HIM ON A
PRETEXT, THEY ALREADY KNEW HE
HAD SPOKEN WITH THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR BECAUSE THEY HAD THE
CALL TRANSCRIPT BUT THEY SET UP
THIS INTERVIEW IN HOPES THAT HE
WOULD STEP INTO A PERJURY TRAP.
ONE FORMER FBI HEAD OF INTEL
NOTED BEFORE THE FLYNN MEETING
REVEALED LAST WEEK, THEY SHOWED
JUST THAT.